welcome back to understanding Quantum information and computation my name is John watus and I'm the technical director for education at IBM
Quantum this is lesson number 14 of the series and it's the second lesson of the fourth unit which is on Quantum error
correction in the previous lesson we took a first look at Quantum error correction including the nine Cubit Shore code which establishes that
Quantum error correction is possible in theory we also discussed the discretization of Errors which allows us
to correct for arbitrary Quantum errors on cubits by effectively projecting them onto bit flips and phase
flips in this lesson we'll discuss the stabilizer formalism which is a mathematical tool through which we can
specify and analyze a broad class of quantum error correcting codes known as stabilizer codes this includes the 9 Cubit Shore
code along with many other examples including codes that are likely to be much better suited to real world Quantum
Computing devices than the shore Cod code not every Quantum error correcting code is a stabilizer code but many are
including every example that we'll see in this series there are certainly interesting and potentially useful Quantum error
correcting codes that aren't stabilizer codes but they tend to be rather more complicated and in any case there's no
question that the stabilizer formalism is a Cornerstone in the foundation of quantum error correction and we'll be
relying heavily upon it for the remainder of the unit here's a brief overview of the lesson we'll start out with a short discussion
of poly matrices and tensor products of poly matrices which can represent both operations on cubits as well as
measurements of cubits as I'll explain and in this context we often refer to them as observables we'll then go back and have
a second look at the repetition code and we'll see how we can describe it through poly operations and observables and that will both inform
and lead into a general discussion of stabilizer codes including several examples basic properties of stabilizer
codes and how we can go about performing the fundamental tasks of encoding detecting errors and correcting those
errors we'll begin the lesson with a brief discussion of poly operations mainly to set the stage for the
stabilizer formalism but also to observe a few key facts and establish some basic terminology first here are the poly
matrices including the 2x2 identity Matrix as well as the three non-identity poly matrices which will denote by
capital X X Y and Z throughout the remainder of the series all four of these matrices are both unitary and herian and we can
identify them with operations on a cubit including operations we might choose to perform as well as errors as we
discussed in the previous lesson the non-identity poly matrices X Y and Z anticommute with one another
meaning that XY is equal to -1 * YX XZ is equal to negative ZX and YZ is equal
to negative z y and you can easily check these relations by doing the multiplications these anti-commutation
relations are very simple but they're critically important in the stabilizer formalism and elsewhere and specifically
as we'll see these minus signs that pop out when we exchange The Ordering of two different non-identity poly matrices in a product correspond precisely to the
detection of errors in the stabilizer formalism we also have the multiplication rules listed here each
polymatrix is its own inverse which is consistent with the fact that they're both unitary and herian and if you multiply any two different non-identity
poly matrices together you'll always get plus or minus I times the remaining non-identity
polymatrix in particular up to a global phase Y is equivalent to X time Z which explains our focus on x and z errors in
Quantum error correction X represents a bit flip Z represents a phase flip and so up to a global phase y represents
both of these errors occurring on the same Cubit these four matrices all represent
operations or errors or the absence of an error on a single Cubit but it's often convenient to tensor them together
to perform operations or errors on multiple cubits as a point of terminology whenever we refer to an N Cubit poly
operation we mean a tensor product of any n poly matrices such as the examples shown
here it's also common to use the term poly operation when there's a global phase but to keep things as simple as possible
I'm going to use the term poly operation to mean simply a tensor product of poly matrices the weight of an incubate poly
operation is simply the number of non-identity poly matrices in the tensor product for example the n-fold tensor
product of the 2 x two identity Matrix with itself is a weight zero poly operation a tensor product of two polyx
matrices and a whole bunch of identity matrices has weight two and so on intuitively speaking the weight of an N
Cubit poly operation is the number of cubits on which it acts non-trivially and it's typical that Quantum error correcting codes are
designed so that they can detect and correct errors represented by poly operations up to a certain weight we can
think about poly operations in various ways including as operations performed intentionally by Quantum Gates as well
as errors and we'll also see shortly that poly operations can describe measurements sometimes it's also useful
to think about poly operations as generators of certain sets in an algebraic sense that you may recognize
if you're familiar with group theory if you're not familiar with group Theory that's okay it's really not essential
for this lesson but if you're interested in studying Quantum error correction in Greater depth you may find that some
basic group theory is very helpful for doing that anyway let's suppose that P1 through PR are n Cubit poly operations
so P1 is an ncit poly operation P2 is an ncit poly operation and so on when we refer to the set generated by
P1 through p r what we mean is the set of all matrices that we can obtain by multiplying these matrices together in
any combination and in any order we choose taking each one as many times as we like we'll see a few examples in just
a moment but first let me mention the notation that we use to denote this set the set generated by P1 through PR and
it's P1 through PR separated by commas inside of angled brackets it does kind of look like we could easily confuse
this notation with direct notation but that doesn't generally happen and this is the traditional notation in group
Theory here's an example of the set generated by X Y and Z so n is equal to one in this example because there are no
tensor products and we're taking all three non-identity poly matrices as generators it turns out that there are
16 matrices that can be generated by forming products that include these three matrices and you can reason this
through the multiplication rules that we saw earlier specifically we can of course get X Y and Z as well as the identity
and in fact we can also get any of these four matrices time I 1 or negative I and that's